so I know you've called yourself a jump
scare guy and jump scares sometimes get
a get a bad reputation I don't like that
I want one do with crafting a good jump
scare but then I also want one do not
when crafting a good jump scare okay so
I think crafting a good jump scare is
about
understanding what the audience is
expecting from you so putting the
audience in a situation where they feel
like they know the road map of how
you're going to get there you know it's
like having the bad version would be
somebody opening a mirror cupboard and
then closing it and someone's behind
them you know it's amazing how kind of
like
um
how much of an understanding audiences
have of the language of horror you know
if you Pan the camera away and then you
pan it back they're going to expect some
to be there like playing
with a familiar Rhythm and then playing
the offbeat going a bit too early or
going a bit too late or playing a scene
in the daytime where the audience kind
of there's a kind of um the the code of
conduct says oh I'm safe in the daytime
and these characters are sitting having
a cup of tea and then suddenly there's a
Red Demon behind you know things like
that James one is amazing at doing this
he knows it's filled with them filled
with them and that you know most of them
most of them are so great
um so I think that's I think that's the
that's the do and then the the don't is
well don't do anything that's familiar
don't don't just like
the worst thing and this is like this is
the biggest Testament to how great our
producers were on this don't try and
turn something that wasn't designed as a
jump scare into a jump scare somebody
opening a door and entering a room
really fast don't put a big musical stab
on that and pretend it's a jump scare
because it'll never work oh that's so
true that happens a lot so much and you
see it so much in movies that are like
have clearly been re-edited or taken out
of the director's hands they just don't
understand the language of horror this
is very specific but do you have an
absolute favorite jump scare like the
first one that you saw that really made
you appreciate it as a craft and kind of
set a template for you I don't know if
it's my favorite but the one that I
remember just being really electrified
by was the um the the scene where she's
watching TV and Conjuring 2 and just the
amount of because it's all you know it's
all it's all like look over here while
you slap somebody around the back of the
head with the other hand it's like it's
all misdirection and the amount of like
places that the scare could emerge in
that scene and then how he finally pays
it off is just genius that's such a good
example do you watch Mike Flanagan stuff
lovely Flanagan one of the best jump
scares of all time is in episode 8 of
Hell House where they're in their car
and they're having a conversation and
you're so invested in what they're
saying and then all of a sudden yeah
I've never jumped that much in my life I
was one of the ones we referenced for
our smash through the door jump scare
that is a good jump scare yeah a plus
jump scare right there
um you brought up uh the studio and I
know you've said that they gave you a
whole lot of leeway and that creative
freedom came as a pleasant surprise
because you know a lot of people assume
that when you are making a studio horror
film there are certain like Studio gods
that you need to appease going into
filming which particular scene or thing
that you wanted to do in the movie did
you think they were going to say no you
can't do that and then it surprised you
that you were allowed to have that
creative freedom with that well two
things I mean we we decided very shortly
before we started shooting that this was
a PG-13 movie which of course it should
be but I was still I still kicked off a
bit
um and I was afraid that I was afraid
the opening would be softened where we
we go very hard very quickly with a with
a um a scarcity in the beginning of the
movie which I never thought would get
past the npaa and there's there's a
scene where Vivian's uh Sawyer is
attacked for the first time
um that culminates in a very violent
thing that happens between her and a TV
that I that I was afraid they would
start cutting into that because that was
designed and conceived and we spent so
long working that's one take that ends
with this moment of life that I never
thought would have and then also I just
thought they'd tell me to cut all the
boring character stuff the boring
character stuff I never thought that
we'd be able to have
um a five minute scene of just Sophie
and Chris sat on the bed talking but not
really talking about the mum and just to
have an understated they both are in
that scene it's such a quiet moment that
you wouldn't expect in a movie like this
the scares aren't scary without Quiet
Moments exactly and they got that yeah
one doesn't work without the other just
because I'm curious and again I think
PG-13 was the right way to go and you
really do the absolute most in terms of
making things feel like our rated scares
even though you have that rating if they
had said okay make an R-rated Boogeyman
what would have been different other
characters just would have sworn a lot
more and no that was a there was a scene
um with the with the I don't know how
spoiler we're getting but there's a
scene where there's a broken bone we
don't see in the movie okay that
initially I wanted it to be like The
Descent where you see that glint of bone
popping out but it probably would have
been too much you were filled with good
references yeah you said them during the
Q a the other night too they were just
like oh it was a laundry list of titles
that I'm like yes yes in my office we
had movies just running in the
background I had a stack of DVDs and
Blu-rays references for the film and
they'd just be playing so even if we
were doing a meeting about something
else people would just be absorbing
these movies through osmosis do you have
a horror movie that you re-watched the
most like when you know every single
line of dialogue too yeah probably Evil
Dead too oh that's a good choice just
the best that's a good choice it's a
good time for horror right now between
this and Evil Dead rise it makes me
happy yeah
um I have to bring up something we were
talking about at the Q a because I want
it on camera in my interview right now
the lightsaber switch oh yeah so can you
just so everyone has the necessary
background can you talk us through the
decision to switch the lightsaber the
moon ball yeah so originally the script
was written with Sawyer's character
having a knockoff lightsaber that she
would hug in bed that would then Fritz
out during the scene that then became
the moon ball scene and um
we we literally our office was filled
with different Lightsaber toys because
we had to we had to find the perfect
lightsaber so we were constantly having
frustrated lightsaber battles during
during prep
um then Disney uh you know I I
completely forgotten that we cast young
Princess Leia and Disney didn't really
like the idea of young Princess Leia
having a broken lightsaber that was
fritzing out it wouldn't look like a
piece of so
um so they said no we can't do that and
we had to come up with something else
very quickly so me and and Jeremy and
Jamie and the production design team had
to just basically Google kids toys that
light up and we found this Moon ball
that ended up being way better we wrote
those scares just in an afternoon and it
became such an integral part of the part
it's such a perfect example of a
creative pivot for the better where you
never would have found the better option
had you not had to steer away from
something that you got to know for
completely and it becomes our it's our
image that rather than the borrowed one
so just just curious in the original
script when you had the lightsaber how
was that particular scene shot and
designed compared to what you were able
to do with the moon ball I wanted to do
something this this was what my
lightsaber used to do my my knock off
one it would like the light would go
from the bottom from the base all the
way to the end and I had this idea of it
almost being like a like a um the beam
of a lighthouse so it should be pointing
it down the hall and it would go all the
way up to the end of the hall and then
go dark again and there we go up to it
so it kind of had a similar effect of
like the you know what you can see and
what you can't see
um and then the idea was yeah that it
would go light and you'd see something
move the end the hall and then the light
would move towards soil and as that
light comes towards soil you see the
creatures actually behind her which
would have been really cool really
really cool but I do think you get a
very similar effect from the ball yeah
no the ball works the ball works it's
brilliant and it's your thing now too
which I love exactly um of all of the
in-story lighting that you used which
other than that did you find the most
challenging to to make work within the
story and also to photograph too oh the
the video game sequence was such was
such a nightmare making sure that good
because Eli
um Eli born our incredible
cinematographer he lights in a very like
beautifully Sim simple way like a lot of
the scenes are lit
with mostly what you see in shot and
then a little bit of help from outside
he's not one of these people that has
like 600 likes and flags and stuff
he wanted to light that whole scene with
the actual video game so he had the vid
he had this screen linked up to other
lights that were also spitting out the
same image so the whole scene was lit
with this reflective light which gives
it this beautifully kind of textured
look but it just um getting that getting
that just right was uh was really
difficult and there was a it was a real
game that she's playing and the the
level that we liked for the light that
she's playing you could only be on that
level for about two minutes before uh
the Sea of red Creeps in which is
actually a thing that's in the game just
happened to work perfectly for us so we
only had a two minute window every time
we'd have to play from the beginning of
the level to this place sit here there
roll and we'd have to finish it before
the evil red villain comes and catches
up with us so let's see it's exceptional
I feel like you two should make another
movie together and work on that lighting
system and then hone it make it work and
just use it as an excuse to make another
film yeah hell yeah I want to work with
Eli on everything yeah something else uh
Hellraiser right this is one of the most
recent ones this movie super dark times
which I love yeah very talented person
there I wanted to go back to the
original draft because I had a question
about will yeah how did how will
approaches tackling this situation and
how he process it change from that
original draft where he was the
protagonist to the new draft that we now
see in the finished film where he's more
supporting character I think it was um
the biggest uh the biggest change was
that he uh he was kind of hearing these
stories from his kids that there's this
creep there's this creature in the house
um and he was being both kind of just
disbelieving you know um it's all in
here he was kind of therapizing them
that you know the original draft was
playing much more into this thing of the
therapist who can't talk about himself
but that was the kind of central drama
um and yet he kind of went and still
investigated he went to to um to visit
Rita billing so I think it was maybe in
an insane asylum or something I can't
remember exactly what it was but he so
he was the the thing that was tricky
with it is that he remained he was
remaining
in disbelief throughout the whole movie
until the very end but he was our
protagonist so it was a kind of like it
was like Scully in The X-Files he would
like experience these horrifying things
but still have some rational way out
which was just it was there was a lot of
interesting stuff that came from it it
was just that that tension was really
hard to keep going throughout 90 minutes
understandable plus Sophie Thatcher is
just one Hector and Chris Messina is
still able to make will feel like a full
person even though he is in a supporting
capacity yeah and he gets to do much
more emotional stuff now now that he's
not dealing with the nuts and bolts of
the creature stuff he gets to do these
beautifully
um nuanced scenes to do with The
Grieving the conversation between the
two of them in the bedrooms one of my
favorite scenes in the entire film
now it's time for my obnoxiously
specific movie Bible type questions
about about your Boogeyman the the first
thing I want to know is do you in this
world at least Envision this Boogeyman
being the only Boogeyman or are there
more of its kind doing the same thing to
other people in the world I'd like to
think there was only one it probably
doesn't makes it's it's like it's like
Santa Claus you know it's like it it
doesn't really make sense but you want
to think there's only one even though
it's impossible that he would be in all
the houses at once it's like I think
this creature it's the it's the boogie
man I think if he's got if he's got a
squadron it makes him less special okay
so with the design of the boogeyman now
I know you were telling us that it has
Battle Scars on it and we only see those
Battle Scars for like the shortest uh
the shortest minute I think in the film
but of all the ones that you guys placed
if you could pick one and explore how it
got that battle scar which would you
want to do the ones that I thought that
were the most impressive with the fresh
wounds from from Rita's shotgun blast I
mean we had you know I like I'd love to
be one of those directors that has a
story for every single Scar and scratch
on the on the Boogeyman and I'm sure the
amazing artists at folks who animated
the creature probably do but um but I
wanted I wanted this sense of this
creature takes on damage every time you
see it
um and they yeah you can you can watch
it and you can see that it starts out
kind of
um it starts out a bit more bloody and
fresh and by the end of the movie It's
kind of started to Wolverine itself back
together I'm one of those jerks that
when I am able to watch the movie at
home I will pause and examine every
single detail of that creature so much
for you so going to the the shotgun
blast and also their family in general
just for your own head and maybe to talk
with um Marin and David too did you ever
discuss how the boogeyman came to their
house did someone pass it along to them
as well the idea that we always came up
with was was
this creature kind of grows investors in
um in suffering and in you know the the
ultimately
um you know they lost three kids the
first one the first child actually died
of Sids and it was in that kind of um
vacuum of of grief that the creature was
able to take up residence and I don't
know who necessarily bought it to them
but the idea is it was born of real
tragedy just in the same way that it is
when it comes to the Harper's house as
if tragedy is not hard enough then you
just add to it life just kicks you when
you're down here's another question
about a horror Trope that people usually
pick on that I'm wondering about here
it's the idea where like if the
boogeyman is in your house just leave do
you think it's the type of situation
where if they had left that house the
boogeyman would have stayed in the house
it infested or would it have found a way
to follow them no it follows them it
follows them in fact that was one of the
only changes that we made from the first
screenings we added in an extra line for
Marin to say which is going to follow
you wherever you go which you know it's
one of the great things Insidious has
done for us that once you explain it's
not the house it's the kid as soon as
you as soon as you like hinted that
logic the audience kind of goes oh okay
I get it it's Insidious oh now I'm so
curious when you went through the test
screening process other than that what
would you say is the the best Note you
got that made you glad you went through
that process with the film I think that
was useful I mean and again I was really
afraid that the studio were going to say
oh we've got to add a whole other scene
where we see the boogeyman's origin
story but we just added this one line
and that was enough nobody asked any
questions about the origin of the
creature
um and then it was just it really it was
just it was just a couple of a couple of
scares and moments didn't quite didn't
quite land as hard as I knew they could
have and so we it was shots here and
there to to just make sure we had enough
build up to get there whether it's test
screenings or any form of note giving
I'm always very impressed by someone who
is able to pinpoint the right notes to
apply but also know when to stick to
their own Vision yeah it's good it makes
you makes you argue it makes you argue
your point and realize why you actually
care what you're invested in and um and
sometimes that sometimes the the note or
the idea is wrong but the sentiment
behind it is right and that 99 of the
case no the evolution this went through
was Sparta and you landed in a very very
successful place oh my God I love this
movie congratulations thanks so much I
mean
I'm scared yes this is why I come here
for these things it was great no what
were your notes on that that was the
first time doing it